The human brain isn't fully developed until you're 25.
So when she entered that relationship at 21,
there wasn't a lot of guidance in her life.
He's just made some really weird statements.
Like, she brings out the best in me.
Sir, you're 40 fucking three years old.
You were graduating high school when she was being born.
And something in hers bringing out the best in you.
Shouldn't you be your best version when you're entering a marriage
so that the two of you can just like, go fast and forward in life?
Like, the reason why grown ass women
still need to talk to other grown ass women
is because when we keep our fucking stories silent,
we don't realize where the abuses are happening.
We can't just allow men to be the only ones to tell the story.
We have to talk and we have to share our stories to help each other.
If you don't wanna listen,
that's on you.
Go get it.
You do, you find you some fucking do whatever the fuck you want.
I really don't care.
I'm just saying I'm not gonna stop talking about it
because it does fucking matter.
It absolutely matters
for grown ass women to talk to other grown ass women.
Cause nobody knows what the fuck they're doing.